did somebody at the biden administration
or in the pine administration
update this guidance for political
reasons
no our north star has been listening to
the guidance of our health and medical
experts and teams and that's exactly
what we're doing in this case
the white house playing defense after
republicans claim the announcement on
mask wearing was meant to distract
from other problems facing president
biden and the cdc director
she's taking heat over her dramatic turn
in messaging
after previously warning of impending
doom that was just a few weeks ago
a former top health official taking
issue with comments like that
but this has been a crazy week just last
week the cdc
said unless we continue everything
masking
social distancing cases would go up
wednesday night
dr wolinski was doubling down on masking
yesterday morning
tony fauci said yeah we still have to
mask in groups outside and of course
inside
and then a complete turnaround yesterday
afternoon we got to the right place
but boy it has been a mess of messaging
but not everyone is on board with the
new mask rules many blue states are
still
evaluating their mandates and some in
the media
well they say it's going to take a while
for americans to adapt
i feel like i'm going to have to rewire
myself so that when i see somebody out
in the world who's not wearing a mask i
don't instantly think
you are a threat or you are selfish or
you are a covid denier and you
definitely haven't been vaccinated
i mean we're going to have to rewire the
way that we look at each other
will kane let me start with you i think
uh it's been good news
uh coming from the cdc but here we see
rachel maddow saying she's going to have
to rewire her thinking what does will
kane say
well i can't i can't follow you
juan on this idea that it's good news i
don't feel like any finish line was
crossed i feel like this is science in
the cdc
and let me say science and quotation
marks following common sense this is
something that everyday americans have
known for months
that you can walk around outside and
even inside if you're vaccinated without
a mask
no the the white house and the cdc have
made these decisions for political
reasons and we can debate what those
political reasons may be
but i do find it fascinating as you ask
me about rachel maddow because what that
reveals to me is even for everyday
people walking around
this has been about something more than
science rachel maddow and many were
finding their cheap
unearned virtue in wearing a mask when
someone else did not they saw themselves
as believers in science
now they've lost their identity juan
they have literally been left naked not
at the face
but in the terms of not having an
identity anymore they don't know how to
project their supremacy
their virtue over you anymore it was
never about science for them
all right well jesse uh you just heard
will say he thinks it's about
politics and virtue signaling but you
know i noticed 70 percent of americans
think that
president biden's done a great job on
handling the pandemic
so did he just pass the biggest test of
his presidency
i'm just trying to come to terms with
will kane's rachel maddow naked analogy
just give me a minute got it
remember slick willy he was wagging the
dog he was
lobbing cruise missiles into the mid
east during the height of the lewinsky
scandal
that's all this is this is pr101 and you
know
what it was because that morning this
mask announcement wasn't on the biden
white house schedule
and he was late for the announcement now
biden has the lightest schedule since
eisenhower
he doesn't do much each day and so when
they add to his schedule
it's a really big deal and he was late
and that's because they were scrambling
to get this out here he doesn't watch
cable news
the president he only reads the
newspapers and the other morning
all over every newspaper especially the
washington post
big stories about how inflation the
labor shortage
and gas prices were all converging to
upset his infrastructure deal
and upset the recovery so they played
this card
and trump did it all the time so can you
blame him he was a lot better at it he
did it with his fingers
or his mouth and sent the press
scrambling so when biden does it
not too good at it so it's a little
blatant
when he does it i did get excited in the
beginning when they made the
announcement i thought great no masks
and then i realized it was just federal
guidance
so they're saying i can not wear a mask
when i go inside a federal building
when am i ever in a federal building
juan when i go to the post office
i never go to the post office in new
york de blasio and cuomo and all the
restaurant owners still make me wear a
mask
so it's status quo if you're in a red
state probably no mask mandate blue
state you still have it
so unless you're in a post office this
doesn't do much for me
huh well kennedy uh you know in fact
picking up on jessie's thought there
nancy pelosi says you still have to wear
a mask
on the house floor and i think part of
her
rationale is like the new york yankees
just had an
outbreak and they've all been vaccinated
but like eight members of their
traveling
i believe one of the players even still
got the virus
what do you how do you make sense of
this well as an epidemiologist juan i'm
really glad you asked me that
question because i've got some charts
and data here to uh outline everything
for you uh with nancy pelosi it's really
just about
control and she she won't listen to
science
she has many doctors in
the house of representatives who could
explain to her
uh that natural immunity from people
who've already had the virus plus
people who've been vaccinated and have
received immunity that way
that's enough people that if they choose
to not wear masks they
they shouldn't have to wear masks so
this is the government
fighting with itself and we're not
talking about a 15 degree
shift with some positive numbers about
hospitalizations and deaths being down
we are talking about a 180 degree turn
in the opposite direction in a number of
weeks uh jen saki says that the north
star
is the medical experts and and they
follow the medical experts well the
medical experts
are following the teachers union so
science is really
uh the the last entity in line here that
is informing some of these decisions
it is absolutely wag the dog but at
least the dog is being wagged in the
right direction
in in the direction of freedom and i
will take that
that's a good point so martha i think
lots of people
on the right in fact wanted the cdc
and joe biden to say let's you don't
need to wear the mask
if you've been vaccinated and yet here
we are and people are criticizing them
for saying don't wear the mask so is
this just partisan politics
yeah it's a lot of partisan politics
it's a lot of white house
opportunism in terms of timing because
yes it's been a really lousy week for
the bite administration
the truth is that across the country
there have been a lot of places that
have lifted the mass mandates a long
time ago so those folks are wondering
what everybody's so excited about and as
jesse points out in new york uh
they're still going to hang on to their
masks for a while but the thing i want
to make a point about here
is herd immunity which was uh sort of
you know like a dirty word you weren't
allowed to talk about herd immunity
the fact of the matter is that the
reason they were they were able to make
this decision
from the cdc is that we have 36 percent
of the country vaccinated and kennedy
was just touching on this point
not too long ago dr fauci said you'd
have to get to 70 or 80 percent
he he basically pushed back marty mccary
the doctor that we all talked to a lot
on fox who said that we were getting
really close to herd immunity he said it
was probably going to happen in the end
of april
so what happened is you got about a
third of the country fully vaccinated
suddenly you started to see all of the
case numbers dropping and the death
number's dropping
the reason for that is because there are
fewer and fewer places for the virus to
go
and that's because a lot of people had
it who didn't know they had it
or they have t cell immunity so all of
the theories that marty mccary has been
talking about for some time in a very
logical straightforward way
that were basically mocked by dr fauci
have given them this opportunity to get
to the point that they got to yesterday
and they did it at a moment that they
really needed it
but that is that is the fact it's
difficult to see this any other way
well i i hope you're comfortable now
without the mass martha
uh are you going to have to change like
rachel all the time i'm the person who
had to use like the disposable one all
the time because i was constantly
forgetting to bring it i will have no
problem dropping the mask i will be
thrilled to drop the mask
um you know rachel maddow can keep her
mask on if she wants to for as long as
she likes
i i think it's really sad that she
looked at people
as her as a threat as an anti-vaxxer as
someone who was
basically had some sort of evil
intention because they were
outside and they were walking in the
area where she was walking guess how
many
traceable cases there are of cova
transmission outside
next to none next to none right okay so
that was that whole idea that whole idea
was was a fallacy to begin with and we
now
know that she'll find a new way to feel
superior we know
we know that now hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else